Speaker 1: Let's try Mark from New Jersey
instead, Mark from Jersey.
You're on the air.
David, how are you?
I'm doing very well.
Speaker 2: Awesome.
So I was wondering, you know, in today's current
vaccine situation, there's a lot of misinformation
that's preventing people from getting vaccines.
But do you think a positive misinformation
campaign could lead to good results, something
like, you know, having bald guys say, oh,
help me regrow my hair and things like that,
almost my status?
Speaker 1: So, no, I mean, so the answer is
yes, it might work.
I mean, listen, the people who buy the supplements,
the people who do all the crazy, you know,
if you're if you would fall for that, they
probably would at least some of them fall
for, you know, the vaccine regrew my hair,
gave me muscle mass and works like, you know,
an erectile dysfunction pill or whatever.
I'm sure it would convince some people, but
I don't think it's a great idea.
What I what I would be more OK with would
be something like.
Calling it trump juice and marketing it like
a soda, and as I tweeted, I think that would
get some Republicans on board.
I tweeted about this earlier this week and
a lot of people latched on to it.
They thought it was a good idea.
Start spreading the rumor that Democrats are
glad Republicans aren't getting vaccinated
because that means they're going to die.
And then maybe Republicans would be like,
screw you, watch me go and get vaccinated
like that.
But but straight up lies like it'll regrow
hair I wouldn't be on board with.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
So I know if people were saying Bill Gates
is going to mind control people, but if they
framed it where the vaccine protects you from
Bill Gates mind control like that,
Speaker 1: I totally know what you're saying.
I totally know what you're saying.
It would work for some people.
I would just listen.
I think it would be more benign to just, hey,
promote it is the Trump vaccine, if that's
what you believe.
Trump made the vaccine and Trump took the
vaccine be like Trump.
I think that would basically work as well
as the regrow hair thing.
And it feels less obviously dishonest, although
it's still dishonest, but in a less empirically
concerning way.
Speaker 2: Right.
Thanks, man.
My pleasure.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Yeah, there's a lot of work to be done there,
that's for sure.
Got to figure out what will work with these
people.